i disagree with you uh
and i was wondering um i i personally
i'm a progressive
and um you know i was just wondering
with our current uh
political atmosphere right now um why is
it that
we have strayed away from not not just
right or or left or just general people
in politics stray away from facts
and try to twist around the truth for
example like
with at fox msnbc all these big
corporate
news programs they tend to have an
agenda
why is it that it's so hard to get facts
out to people i mean i think it's always
been hard to get facts out to people is
the truth i think that narrative has
always
been more prominent in our mind what we
want to believe i mean confirmation bias
is obviously a very prevalent thing what
you want to believe
you tend to you tend to believe and you
tend to look for excuses to believe it
i think that an era of mass media where
every taste can be catered to you see
that a lot more often
obviously and so if you think like
rachel maddow you're likely to watch
rachel mata if you think like sean
hannity you're likely to watch sean
hannity and have all your biases
confirmed
that's one of the reasons why i hope
that i'm at least attempting to
present facts even some facts that
disagree with my position and then
explain why
you know those are wrong and if you
present a fact to me that disagrees with
my position i'll acknowledge the fact
i'll either say that it strays from my
framework or not i mean it's something
that i
strive to do maybe i fail but something
i'm trying to do i think that the reason
that people
strayed away from fact and and moved
into subjectivity is because
there's something comforting about
subjectivity you can never be wrong
the thing about facts is that somebody
can prove you wrong it's uncomfortable
to be out there on the limb all the time
waiting for somebody to saw it off
behind you
right doing what i do uh it's a lot of
fun i mean i love what i do for a living
but i will also say that there is a
constant feeling of am i right
and when somebody says you're wrong
you're like if you're a good person you
think well maybe i am wrong let me
examine that
more and it's uncomfortable to feel like
you're wrong every time you feel like
you're wrong it means that you have to
examine your presuppositions and think
about whether
you're si you're saying the right things
and so i take criticism seriously or at
least i try to
um and i think that that's that's a hard
thing to do and especially in an era
where we have been told that there's a
virtue of being offended
that you being offended is a substitute
for you learning something
that if you don't like what i'm saying
then you being offended is enough for
you to just
dismiss it out of hand you don't have to
go home and do any research that's made
things very convenient for people
particularly in everybody's into virtue
signaling now
it's very easy this is why you see these
kind of tsunamis that start
where people will call steven pinker a
racist right i mean stephen pinker is a
lefty
stephen pinker only says that there are
differences in biology
between men and women for example or
he'll say things like i've said that
there are different crime rates in
particular communities and then he'll
get blasted for this as supposedly
upholding alt-right views
that's because people want to believe
that those facts are are not right and
so they will blame his motivation
and then attribute to him a motivation
that he doesn't like so if we can
refrain from questioning each other's
motivation
and go to maybe where we will go wrong
in logic then maybe we can have a
conversation
this by the way is one of the reasons
why even though i'm an orthodox jew i
never cite the bible
in defense of my positions because i
know that a lot of people don't believe
in the bible so we can't have a
conversation on common ground here